non non non
[Musique]
je sais pas c'est qui qu'a filmé 5
jamais dit qu'ils n'ont jamais du cij
et ouvre
l adoption
non mais là c'est ouf c'est ouf parce
que cette cassette ces
de sa mère elle a cramé
elle a dit mathieu
tu me tues genou se retrouver comme un
enfant tu vois qu'ils regardaient les
vidéos de l'époque moment j'ai vu qu'un
premier beau et à les faire
enfin un petit métro pour me détendre
waouh je sais pas où tu as chaud et ça
ça m'a remis le sourire je sais pas si
je sois si vous saurez tout le reste
c'était moi qu'en regardant sa homme est
tout tout petit toute l'histoire du
graffiti
devant dale
m
[Musique]
des vandales quoi salisseurs graffiti
emballe c'est l'essence même du de ce
qu'elle graffiti c'est interdit ça n'a
pas de sens mais c'est ce qui me plaît
quoi c'est certainement la discipline la
plus respectée
c'est la liberté faire ce qu'on veut nos
goûts avec nos rôles c'est un mélange de
peur d'adrénaline d'excitation donc tu
joues avec ça tu veux aussi être par
peur quand tu quand tu fais du graphite
ça c'est des trucs dangereux c'est
illégal c'est interdit par la loi tu ne
fais pas que pour la beauté de du
résultat tu essayes de mélanger un peu
tout ça et c'est ça qui est beau dans le
graffiti
le vandalisme s'est pas forcément kcc
élaborer quelque chose de propre de
construit dans un hors cadre logique
pour nous
essayez un groupe d'amis
au point de vue local et à
l'international
c'est une internationale de graffitis on
va dire dans le point commun c'est un
certain style
[Musique]
c'est des lettres géantes
principalement en chrome avec un contour
les plus grosses possible les plus
utilisés possible pour pouvoir affecter
visuellement le plus de frappes
[Musique]
sont ils ces ya quoi je connais pas ces
mecs les plus nuls du monde
déjà c'était moche à l'époque qu'est ce
que c'est moche aujourd'hui pour prendre
part à cette phase pour l'apprendre
merde
alors les uv peu leur style et caron
paxil cr c'était un peu du grand
n'importe quoi
sert un style qu'on a développée sur sur
plan d'année quoi
allez hue et c'était un groupe qui était
principalement groupe pure vandales
ça pour nous c'est incompréhensible
arrive à rien
ce qui est sûr c'est que cherche pas la
technique ça s'est jamais cherché la
technique
[Musique]
ça m'intéresse pas en fait c'est parce
qu'ils me parlent moi ce qui me parle
c'est plus le côté spontané quoi en fait
de la peinture on se prend pas la tête
mais qd tu sors tu es bon tu traces tu
remplis avec des couleurs moche si
possible tu marron
et c'est ça qui est beau 3
si c'est pour aller saloper de la bombe
et la jdl bêtement je vous vois pas
l'intérêt le plus de force à chercher
l'énergie et la spontanéité dans une
peinture que chercher la technique en
fait ces deux mondes complètement
différents moi je me souviens même qu'il
y avait des mecs qui disait mais
ces mecs là ils peignent de la main
gauche bah ouais si tu veux quoi mais
bon
si on panier comme ça c'est qu'on le
faisait exprès on savait ce qu'on
voulait faire et tant mieux si ça vous
choque vous savez que c'est super grave
vers chez vous il ya plein de trucs
partout
la merde quoi
je m'appelle robin je suis connue dans
le graffiti sous le nom de shadow et de
sites j'ai fait partie de plusieurs
groupes dont les uv originaire darblay
dans le val d'oise
j'ai fait du graffiti pendant dix ans de
89 à 2001
oui manière assez intensive quasiment
presque professionnel complètement
passionné bousillée par ce truc là
mes parents ont toujours su ce que je
faisais on sait on s'est beaucoup parlé
c'est n'avait pas d'interdît il savait
que sortait du cadre mais au moins il
est au courant de ce que je faisais
moi j'ai toujours été très observateur
j'ai toujours observé des graffitis qui
n'était pas du graff en fait slogans
politiques d'être pliée aux cultures
musicales hard rock skin punk et en fait
il ya un petit jeune du quartier qui je
me fais copains qui m'invite chez lui un
samedi après mme qui me met dans les
mains subway art esprit qu'un art je
découvre ses bouquins et je me prend une
grosse claque en fait quoi
il ya cette photo qui est magnifique
août un mec qui courent sur le toit des
métros et celle là je me souviens qu'à
celle ci a vraiment marqué parce que
c'est ça représente la liberté en fait
ça me donne de la force à me donne envie
en faites quoi je me dis ça bouge il se
passe des trucs
le technique dans le graffiti pour moi
ç'a vraiment été le visionnage envoyé
spécial un reportage qui est à 2.90
dernier volet de ce magazine les
tagueurs j'entends déjà certains qui
hurlent au vandalisme et d'autres ligues
crient au génie même si ça vous dépasse
accrochez vous ai dit vous simplement
que c'est peut-être l'une des formes de
culture de cette fin de siècle
[Musique]
tout le monde avait l'info tu nous
attendait les graffeurs on attendait
tous ce truc quoi
paris couvert de tags paris massacre est
retourné cartonné comme disent les
tagueurs andré sur son scooter les 93 m6
qui font 30
quelques minutes suffisent pour 93 mt m
dans l'entrepôt désert de la sncf ils
repeignent les revers à leurs couleurs 4
enfin quelqu'un ça parte guitares funk
ou quoi voilà c'est à l'escale quoi vous
croyez les jeunes gavés de télé abouti
par le top 50 et les voilà qui prennent
les armes bombe et marqueurs en vente
partout au pays des belles et quelques
vocabulaire le flop fait des lettres
flop des boules c'est plutôt rond un peu
gros il ya le batlam j'ai les lettres
carrées quoi je fais des bottoms et des
lettres carrées tu vois je compte dans
ce que je veux non mais franchement leur
partage des mythiques c'est du pur
plaisir quoi c'est de l'adrénaline pure
enfin là c'est surtout fauteuil tuent
ils tanguent sans relâche depuis huit
ans pour la ratp c'est l'ennemi public
numéro un fils de bonne famille il est
devenu voyous juste par amour des cinq
lettres de son nom
bandy39 préfère aujourd'hui rester dans
l'ombre voilà l'important c'est qu'on
voyait mon mur par mois une fois qu'on
commence à payer quand j'en sais plus
possible d'arrêter
bordeaux c'était vraiment un super bass
taking bandeau c'était le king de son
époque dans les années 80 jusqu'au début
des années 90 ce mec est partout dans la
rue
[Musique]
très franchement en terme de ce que nous
on aimait c'était le meilleur
[Musique]
pur site de l'être très américain après
new york c'est quelqu'un de propre et
qui va faire un nombre de graff
incalculables en termes de volume je
crois qu'il ya rien qui pourrait pas de
bandeau sur métier pour moi bordeaux
c'est un des premiers c'est un
précurseur ça a été une révélation pour
beaucoup et il a insufflé l'envi de
peindre énormément de brightest dans
paris
conditions
[Musique]
s'asseoir et tout me royal et puis tu
tues présente
je m'appelle philipp lehmann était
attaché pas vu le film mais en plus je
le remercie
[Musique]
je m'appelle philipp lehmann j'étais un
des premiers à commencer les graffitis
en europe en france et je t'avais
bandeau